simplifica la expresión eliminando todos
los factores que sean cuadrados
perfectos dentro de los radicales y
combinan los términos y tengo esta
expresión de clint la expresión no se
puede simplificar introduce la como está
bien lo primero que se me ocurre es que
pausa es el vídeo e intentas hacerlo por
tu cuenta una vez que lo hayas intentado
vamos a resolverlo juntos muy bien vamos
a intentarlo juntos y lo primero que
quiero que veas es lo siguiente 45 este
de aquí lo puedo escribir como 9 por 5 9
por 5 es 45 así que esta parte de aquí
en esta primera parte déjeme tratarla
con este color lo voy a ver de la
siguiente manera me va a quedar como 7
que multiplica a la raíz de 9 que esto a
su vez multiplica a la raíz de 5
y es que observa 9 por 5 45 ahora bien
lo estoy escribiendo de esta manera
porque 9
es un cuadrado perfecto así que le
podemos sacar una raíz cuadrada de
manera exacta y eso nos va a servir
bastante 5 no pero vamos a trabajarlo
así y después me queda lo siguiente
tengo más dos veces la raíz de 125 bueno
pues 125 lo podemos escribir como bueno
es lo mismo que 5 al cubo con 25 por 5
esto es lo mismo que 25 por 5 así que
toda esta segunda parte que tengo aquí
la puedo escribir de la siguiente manera
como 2 que va a multiplicar a la raíz de
25 que a su vez va a multiplicar a la
raíz de 5 y de nuevo observa que 25 es
un cuadrado perfecto por lo tanto a
sacar la raíz me va a quedar un número
exacto y bueno abajo tengo en la raíz de
65 pero 65 es lo mismo que 13 por 5 y
bueno
y cinco tienen raíz cuadrada exacta así
que lo voy a dejar todavía como la raíz
de 65 la raíz de 65 ahora bien la raíz
de 9 esta de aquí tiene una raíz exacta
su raíz estrés por lo tanto la raíz
principal de 9 voy a decir que es 3 y me
va a quedar 7 por 3 por la raíz de 5 y
pasa lo mismo con la raíz de 25 su raíz
principal su re dispositiva es 5 así que
lo voy a poner así va a quedar 2 por 5
por la raíz de 5 y bueno eso nos da bien
a que toda esta parte de aquí la puede
escribir la siguiente manera me va a
quedar 7 por 3 es 21 por la raíz de 5
entonces es 21 por la raíz de 5 ok ya
esto le voy a sumar es justo esta parte
que tengo aquí a esto le voy a sumar 2
por 5 por la raíz de 5 lo cual es 10
veces la raíz
de 5 muy bien y a todo esto lo voy a
dividir entre la raíz de 65 entre la
raíz de 65 muy bien ahora observa 21 de
algo más 10 de algo eso se puede sumar
estos dos la suma de estos dos me va a
dar lo mismo que 31 veces que 31 veces
la raíz de 5 la raíz de 5 y bueno claro
esto entre en la raíz de 65 que no lo
olvidemos entre la raíz de 65 ahora bien
creo que esto se puede simplificar
todavía un poco más porque si observas
la raíz de 65 esto es exactamente lo
mismo
déjame ponerlo así esta parte de abajo
me queda como la raíz de 13 la raíz de
13 por la raíz de 5 y arriba tengo 31
por la raíz de 5 recuerdas 31
la raíz de 5 ahora observa aquí tengo
una raíz de 5 multiplicando y una raíz
de 5 dividiendo 1 en el numerador y una
en el denominador así que las podemos
cancelar y simplemente voy a quedarme
con 31 31 que está dividido entre la
raíz de 13 déjame ponerlo con este color
entre la raíz de 13 ok esto lo podemos
escribir de esta manera o también lo
podemos ver para finalizar como la raíz
cuadrada de algo sobre 13 y quién es ese
algo bueno pues 31 al cuadrado y cuántos
31 al cuadrado déjame escribirlo aquí 31
por 31 esto es lo mismo que 1 por 11 1
por 3 33 por unas 3 y 3 x 39 y si
sumamos me va a quedar 9
así que esto va a ser la raíz cuadrada
de 961 entre 13 y esto lo hago porque la
raíz cuadrada ya no me queda en la parte
de abajo entonces vamos a escribirlo
esto de aquí me va a quedar como la raíz
cuadrada de 961 esto dividido entre 3 y
ya está
esta es la respuesta de este ejercicio
muy bien como me gustó mucho vamos a
hacer uno más y para eso voy a quitar
este de aquí y vamos a traer este nuevo
ejercicio que dicen realiza las
operaciones indicadas y tengo raíz de 10
más raíz de 7 por raíz de 10 más raíz de
7 bien pues de nuevo pausa el vídeo y
ver si puedes resolverlo por tu cuenta
bueno vamos a trabajarlo juntos y para
eso lo primero que quiero que veas es
que esto lo podemos resolver como un
binomio cuadrado perfecto o también
podemos usar la regla distributiva dos
veces y de hecho qué te parece si lo
resolvemos de esa manera así que lo
primero que voy a
es tomarme la raíz de 10 más a raíz de 7
esto que tengo aquí y lo voy a
multiplicar primero por la raíz de 10 y
después me voy a tomar esto mismo y lo
voy a multiplicar por la raíz de 7 pero
primero empecemos con esto cuanto es la
raíz de 10 por la raíz de 10 bueno eso
es muy fácil es lo mismo que 10 días y
después me queda la raíz de 7 por la
raíz de 10 eso es exactamente lo mismo
que la raíz de 70 entonces 10 más la
raíz de 70 muy bien y ahora me voy a
tomar la raíz de 10 más a raíz de 7 está
que tenemos primero pero ahora la voy a
multiplicar con este color por la raíz
de 7 me voy a tomar a estas dos y ahora
lo voy a multiplicar por la raíz de 7 y
que me va a quedar bueno la raíz de 10
por la raíz de 7 eso ya lo mismo es lo
mismo que la raíz de 70 lo voy a poner a
si la raíz de 70 y después tengo la raíz
de 7 x
la raíz de 7 bueno eso sabemos que es 77
y ahora sí que voy a obtener de esto
bueno pues observa lo siguiente tengo 10
7 esos 17 muy bien y después tengo
déjame ponerlo con otro color la raíz de
70 más la raíz de 70 esos dos veces la
raíz de 72 veces la raíz de 70 y ya con
esto hemos terminado
nosotros podemos escribir que esto es lo
mismo que 17 más dos veces la raíz de 70
ahora lo único que quiero que veamos
antes de acabar el vídeo es que esto
también lo podemos ver de otra manera
tal vez podrías encontrar el siguiente
patrón esto es muy parecido a tener a
más ven que multiplica a su vez aa más
bien y bueno a más ve por a más bien es
lo mismo que a más
esto elevado al cuadrado y nosotros
sabemos cómo se resuelve un binomio el
cuadrado perfecto estás de acuerdo esto
es lo mismo que a cuadrado más dos veces
a b más de cuadrada y si ahora observas
que vale la raíz de 10 y b vale la raíz
de 7 entonces podemos sustituir los
valores aquí es decir esto me quedaría
como la raíz de 10
la raíz de 7 esto todo esto elevado al
cuadrado va a ser igual que bueno que la
raíz de 10 esto elevado al cuadrado
más dos veces la raíz de 10 por la raíz
de 7 lo único que estoy usando es esta
expresión que tengo aquí más la raíz de
7 la raíz de 7 esto elevado al cuadrado
y bueno esto claramente es lo mismo que
10 más 2 que multiplica a la raíz
cuadrada de 10 por 7 que es 70 más 7 y
esto va a ser lo mismo que 17 más dos
veces la raíz de 70 que es justo a lo
que llegamos acá arriba por lo tanto
hemos resuelto el ejercicio y ya está
esta es la solución